encore une fois mercredi il a été
question du ministre des transports à
l'assemblée nationale après des
révélations du journal de québec
certains se sont demandés si laurent
lessard ne s'est pas placé dans une
situation de conflit d'intérêts alors
qu'il était ministre des affaires
municipales de 2009 à 2012 les
transports le temps qu'on fasse toute la
merde minimum honte à vous que traîner
sa femme travaillait pour un organisme
sans but lucratif qui a obtenu une
subvention de la société d'habitation du
québec qui relevait du ministère de
lessard l'organisme en question est bien
et mène des projets de construction de
logements abordables à 3 sur les places
options loge je comprends bien ce qui se
passe je vous rassure et cathay de faire
de bonnes démarches concertées
la question qui se pose ici
qu'advient-il de votre conjoint ou
conjointe si vous deviez ministre j'ai
lu le code d'éthique et de déontologie
adopté par les députés en 2010 et ce
n'est pas simple mais on peut résumer ça
ainsi si votre conjoint ou votre
conjointe à des intérêts indirectement
ou directement dans une entreprise ça
peut être autorisée à la condition
qu'aucun marché n'implique le ministère
ou un organisme public dont la
responsabilité vous a été confié en tant
que ministre
maintenant est ce qu'un organisme sans
but lucratif est une entreprise
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire exactement
aucun marché pour le savoir on se
tournait vers le commissaire à l'éthique
et à la déontologie et on nous a répondu
que ça prendrait une vérification ou une
enquête du commissaire pour le
déterminer
pour en savoir davantage les et nous ici
pour un radio canada.ca la section
politique